weltweit lückenloser internetzugang für
alle mit starling will ihnen was genau
das möglich machen bis 2027 sollen dafür
knapp 12.000 kleinen satelliten um die
erde kreisen doch schon die ersten 60
testsatelliten sorgten jetzt für hitzige
debatten im netz der grund die
satelliten waren als extrem helle
lichter am himmel zu sehen kritiker und
kritikerin sehen dadurch die
bodengestützte astronomie bedroht und
fürchten zudem die endgültige verbindung
des weltraums was ist an dieser kritik
dran und was hat ihnen macht dazu alles
geht fix unterwegs
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen elon musk der chef des us
amerikanischen raumfahrtunternehmen
spacex will internet mit
höchstgeschwindigkeit für alle menschen
möglich machen und zwar bis zu 1 gigabit
pro sekunde und pro nutzer immer wieder
betont mass dass sein plan unter anderem
darauf abzielt möglicherweise milliarden
von ökonomischen benachteiligten
menschen zu helfen
realisiert werden soll das projekt
skylink mit hilfe von etwa 12.000
kleinen satelliten die in verschiedener
höhe um die erde kreisen 2027 soll diese
mega konstellation an satelliten am
himmel sein ende mai waren die ersten 60
testsatelliten auf dem weg gebracht
worden
doch die reaktion fiel ganz anders aus
als erwartet denn schnell kursierten im
netz videos von den satelliten wie sie
ihre bahn über den nachthimmel zogen
quasi wie an einer schnur aufgefädelt
einer nach dem anderen zum entsetzen
vieler waren sind dabei eben sehr sehr
deutlich am dunklen himmel zu erkennen
der grund dafür die solarpaneele der
star links satelliten reflektierten das
licht der sonne auf die erde
eine hitzige debatte wurde daraufhin
losgetreten zum größten teil auf twitter
wie solle man sich den himmel vorstellen
wenn er demnächst einmal von hunderten
satelliten beleuchtet wird so twitterte
beispielsweise der us astronom alex
parker mit an die dunkelheit angepassten
augen und ohne lichtverschmutzung kann
man rund 9000 stern am nachthimmel sehen
verteilt auf die gesamte himmel sphäre
wenn die 12.000 star längst eliten auch
an ihren endgültigen umlaufbahnen
sichtbar bleiben würde das vielleicht
sogar im schlimmsten fall das ende der
bodengestützte natur
bedeuten schließlich könnten die styling
satelliten sterne und galaxien
überstrahlen oder gar verdecken so die
besorgten tweets doch nicht nur das auch
andere geschehnisse am himmel könnten
uns diesen befürchtungen zufolge durch
die lappen gehen beispielsweise
supernova explosionen oder aber auch
potenziell gefährlicher als zu ihnen
aber auch die internationale
astronomische union hat sich
eingeschaltet die fachleute zeigten sich
besorgt über diese satelliten
konstellation wünschenswert sei demnach
das prinzip eines dunklen und funk
stillen himmels unter anderem auch als
ressource für die gesamte menschheit und
zum schutz nachtaktive tiere die
satelliten stellen den nach einem
bedrohung da auch wenn die absichten
dahinter begrüßenswert sein
die organisation fordert deswegen die
entwicklung eines rechtsrahmens um die
auswirkungen auf die wissenschaftliche
erforschung so bald wie möglich zu
verringern oder zu beseitigen elon musk
selbst äußerte sich per tweet zu diesem
thema doch dadurch heizt er die debatte
noch weiter an denn seiner meinung nach
seien weltraumteleskope die zukunft der
astronomie und biss ihn by anyone
anlässe looking very careful with around
the press and impact on advanced in
astronomie wie need to move teleskop it
anyway außer acht gelassen hat dabei die
tatsache dass erst in der jüngsten zeit
einige gigantische bodengestützten
teleskope gebaut wurden wie
beispielsweise das größte radioteleskop
weltweit das 2016 seinen betrieb
aufgenommen hatte der hauptspiegel des
observatoriums fast 500 meter aperture
das ferkel teleskop hat einen
durchmesser von unglaublichen 530 meter
die chinesen wollen mit seiner hilfe
bahnbrechende entdeckung machen unter
anderem bei der suche nach
außerirdischem leben
zudem seien seines talents satellit nur
während der dämmerung zu sehen da sie
nachts ebenso wie die sterne im dunkeln
sei dieser aussage von musk allerdings
ist nicht ganz korrekt denn die
endgültige umlaufbahn einiger seiner
satelliten liegt in einer höhe von 550
kilometern und dort scheint oft auch die
sonne
wenn bei uns auf der erde tiefste nacht
ist widerspruch bekommt musk von
renommierten astronomen astronomen
beispielsweise von dem niederländischen
astrophysikers es besser seinen
berechnungen zufolge werden diese
eliten vor allem in den sommernächten
immer zu sehen seien demnach würden
allein schon die ersten 1500 sechs
satelliten zu einer enormen charakter
veränderung des himmels führen andere
fachleute sehen das ganze nicht ganz so
pessimistisch doch auch radioastronomen
und astronomen sehen musk vorhaben als
überaus kritisch denn bisher ist nicht
wirklich geklärt ob die funksignale auch
deren sensible empfänger
beeinträchtigten könnten
ein weiterer kritikpunkt der vielen
skeptiker die zunehmende vermüllung des
weltalls doch was hat das alles so nicht
auf sich sitzen lassen und zog ende mai
mit einem weiteren tweet nach kriegsende
motto cycling team nachwuchsfestival
regarding albedo reduction demnach
sollen sich sein team also darum kümmern
den sogenannten albedo zu reduzieren
also denjenigen anteil des lichts den
eine oberfläche absorbiert im fall von
satelliten ein hoher wert da sie viel
licht reflektieren um zu vermeiden dass
sich die elektronik an bord zu sehr auf
reids in einem weiteren tweet versprach
er auch bestimmte frequenzbänder die
eben für die radioastronomie vorgesehen
sind zu meiden auch in sachen
weltraumschrott habe space ex vorgesorgt
denn die jetzt gestarteten satelliten
werden laut einer sprecherin nach ihrer
lebensdauer von etwa fünf jahren in der
erdatmosphäre verglühen und das fast
rückstandsfrei dennoch die kritik an
seinem vorhaben reißt nicht ab
astronomen und bloggerin neu sie hat
dazu eine mehr als deutliche meinung
hier kommt ein mächtiger reicher weißer
judt der großzügig den armen nicht
weisen der welt internet bescheren wird
ohne wert darauf zu legen sie dabei zu
partnern zu machen oder auch nur zu
fragen was sie wirklich brauchen sieht
der himmel also in zukunft ganz anders
aus als wir ihn kennen weil aus ihm ein
einziger satelliten himmel geworden ist
eine frage die derzeit nicht ganz klar
beantwortet werden kann
da einige parameter wie beispielsweise
die ausrichtung der solarzellen noch
unbekannt sind unklar ist bislang zudem
ob solch ein satelliten himmel
tatsächlich ein problem für
hobby-astronomen und astronomen und
riesenteleskope werden könnte
das wird derzeit und auch zukünftig wohl
über unseren köpfen macht space ex
raumfahrt also unmöglich das ist ein
video von raum zeit block der zukunft
anklicken anschauen und
abonieren nämlich den hammer kanal
raumzeit block der zukunft bis dann
bleibt dran